In this video, we will consider
a classical application
of Markov chains, which has to
do with the design of a phone
system.
This is a classical problem,
which was posed, analyzed,
and solved by a Danish
engineer by the name of Erlang.
It was more than 100
years ago when phones just
started to exist,
but the technique
remains relevant today to design
systems of a similar nature.
As for Erlang, he was
trying to figure out
how to design the capacity
of a phone system.
That is, how many
lines should we
set up for a group of
people, say, in a village,
to be able to communicate
to the outside world?
So here is a cartoon
of the problem, where
these are the
phone lines, and we
need to decide how many of these
lines to set up, let's say,
B. How to do that?
Well, we don't want B to be too
large, much more than needed,
because too many lines
would be expensive.
On the other hand, we
want to have enough lines
so that if a reasonable
number of people place phone
calls during the
same period, they
will be able to talk and
not get busy signals.
So if B is 10 and 15 people
want to talk at the same time,
then 5 would get a
busy signal, and that's
probably not what you want as
an acceptable level of service.
So we would like B to be just
large enough so that there
is a high probability
that no one is
going to get a busy signal.
So how do we go about modeling
a situation like this?
Well, we need two
pieces of information,
one describing how
phone calls get
initiated, and once a phone call
gets started, how long does it
take until it ends?
We're going to make some very
simple but somewhat plausible
assumptions.
We will assume that phone calls
originate as a Poisson process.
We will assume that
out of that population,
there is no coordination.
At completely random times,
people pick up their phone
independent of each other's.
Also, there is nothing special
about the various times,
and different times
are independent.
So a Poisson model
is a reasonable way
of modeling a situation
under these assumptions.
We also assume that
the rate lambda
is known or has been estimated.
Now, it might be the case
that during the night,
the rate would be different
than during the day.
In that case, you
would design the system
to meet the largest
rate of the two.
For the phone calls
themselves, we
are going to assume that
the duration of a phone call
is a random variable that has
an exponential distribution
with a certain parameter mu.
So 1/mu is the mean
duration of a phone call.
Duration of phone calls are
independent between each other.
So here, again, we assume
that the parameter mu
has been estimated.
For example, the mean duration
1/mu could be 3 minutes.
Now, is the exponential
assumption a good assumption?
So here is the PDF of an
exponential random variable
with parameter 1 over three.
That means that the mean
duration is about three minutes
here.
So if you look at
this PDF, it means
that most phone calls
will be kind of short.
There is going to be a
fraction of phone calls
that are going to
be larger, and then
a very small fraction
of phone calls
that are going to
be even larger.
So it sounds reasonable.
However, it's not exactly
realistic in some situations.
Typically, phone calls that
last a very short time are not
that common as opposed to what
an exponential distribution
would indicate here.
So some other distribution
might be better, like this one,
for example, here, where during
a very small period of time
the wait corresponding to
this very short period of time
are kind of small as well.
There are many
distributions of this type.
I've just provided here
one simple example.
This one is the Erlang
of parameter 2 and 2/3.
What it means is that
it is the sum of two
independent exponential
random variables,
and each one of them
of parameter 2/3.
So the mean duration associated
with this distribution
is also 3 minutes.
So this might fit better
some practical situation.
But here we will keep the
simple assumption associated
with an exponential
distribution.
All right.
So let's try now to
come up with the models
that we can decide how many
lines, B, do we want to set up.
The Poisson process
run in continuous time.
And call durations being
exponential random variables
are also continuous
random variables.
So it seems that we are in
a continuous time universe.
Here is a cartoon of the
evolution of the system.
So here I have in blue when
phone calls get initiated.
So this is called 1, a second
one, a third, a fourth,
and a fifth one.
And also, I have represented
here the duration of the call.
So call 1 lasted that
long, call 2 lasted long
until here, 3 up to
here, 4 here, et cetera.
So when you look at this
kind of system in that way,
and you run through time
in a continuous manner,
and here you have 0 line busy.
You have 1 line used, 0,
1, then 2 becomes busy,
3, 2, 1, and 0, and
so on and so forth.
Also note that if I look at
that system at any time t,
because of our assumptions
of a Poisson process
and an exponential
duration for phone calls,
and a memoryless
property associated
with these processes, it
means that the past really
has no information
about the future.
And so, in some sense, the
Markov property is valid.
So it looks like a
continuous time Markov
process would be needed here.
And this is indeed an
option, but we have not
studied those in this class.
So we will discretize
time instead
and work with a Markov chain.
We are discretizing time in the
familiar way, the way we did it
when we studied the
Poisson process.
We are going to
take the time axis
and split it into
little discrete time
slots, each of duration delta.
And delta is supposed to be
a very, very small number.
So now under this
discretization,
by the definition of
the Poisson process
the probability that we'll
see 1 arrival during any time
slots of duration delta
will be lambda times delta.
Also, if at any time, like here
we have 1 simple call active,
the probability that this call
will end during any future time
slot of duration delta
is mu delta, like here.
Indeed, as we have
seen in Unit 9,
an exponential
random variable can
be thought of as
representing the time
until the first arrival of a
Poisson process with rate mu.
What if you have i busy
calls at the same time?
Then the probability
of having 1 call ending
in a time slot of duration
delta will be i mu delta.
Like, for example here, this one
could correspond to something
as 2 mu delta.
Indeed, each of the Poisson
processes associated
with these calls
with rate mu can
be combined into a merged
Poisson process of rate i times
mu.
And a call completion will
correspond to the time
until the first arrival of
this merged Poisson process.
For example, if I go back here
in my situation here at time t,
there were still 3
phone calls active.
And I represent here the
call number 2, call number 3,
and call number 4 and
their remaining duration.
And if you look at these
and you combine these 3
associated Poisson
processes into 1,
you get a merged
Poisson process.
And if you look now at the time
arrival of the first event,
which would
correspond to here, it
would be an exponential
random variable.
The duration here
would correspond
to an exponential random
variable of parameter 3 mu.
So in that case, if you go back
to that representation here,
the probability of
a departure would
be 3 times mu times delta.
OK?
So let us continue
with our discrete time
approximation of our system.
Again, we have the village,
and the lines, the B
that we would like to decide.
We have discretized
the time steps.
We have made some approximation.
And we know that during any
of these time slots here,
the probability that
you would get a new call
is about lambda times delta.
Lambda is the rate of
the Poisson process.
And given that you have
i calls, the probability
that one of these calls ends
will be i times mu times delta.
OK.
If we want to propose a Markov
chain model for this system,
we need to specify the
states and the transition
probabilities.
What are the states
of the system?
If you look at the system
at any particular time,
the minimum relevant
information to collect
would be the number
of busy lines,
something like these 2 lines are
busy, or all of them are busy,
or none of them are used.
Now, because of our assumptions,
again, about the Poisson
process arrivals and
exponential duration
of calls and their
memoryless property,
that information is
enough to fully describe
the state of our
system in such a way
that we get a Markov chain.
So the states are numbers
from 0 to B. 0 corresponds
to a state in which all
the phone lines are free.
No one is talking.
B corresponds to a case where
all the phone lines are busy.
And then you've got
states in between.
Now, let us look at the
transition probabilities.
Suppose that right now,
you are in that state.
What can happen next?
Well, a new phone call
gets placed, in which case
the state moves up by 1.
Or an existing call
terminates, in which case
the state goes down by 1.
Or none of the two
happens, in which case
the state stays the same.
Well, it is also possible that
a phone call gets terminated,
and a new phone call gets
placed in the same time period.
But when the duration
of the time slots
are very, very small,
the delta here,
this event is going to have
a negligible probability,
order of delta squared.
So we ignore it, as
we ignore the fact
that more than one
new call can happen,
or more than one call can be
terminated during a given slot.
So what is the probability
of an upward transition?
That's the probability that the
Poisson process has an arrival
during the slots
of duration delta.
And as we have seen, this
is lambda times delta.
So each one of these
upward transitions
has the same probability
of lambda times delta.
How about phone
call terminations?
If we have i phone calls
that are currently active,
the probability that one of them
terminates becomes i mu delta.
So here it would be mu
delta, and here B mu delta.
Now, let us analyze this chain.
It has the birth and
death form that we
discussed in the
previous lecture.
So instead of writing
down the balance equation
in a general form,
we think in terms
of frequency of transitions
across some particular cut
in this diagram, so
for example here.
The frequency with which
transition of this kind
happen or are observed
has to be the same
as the frequency of
transition of this kind.
The frequency of
transition of this type
will be, if you look at pi i
here and pi of i minus 1 here,
this transition here will happen
with pi i times i mu delta.
And the transition
of this type here
will be pi i minus 1
times lambda times delta.
And the frequency
of these transitions
have to be the same as the
frequency of these transitions,
so we have that equals that.
And then we can cancel
the delta in both,
and we are left with
this equation here.
So this equation expresses pi of
i in terms of pi of i minus 1.
So if we knew pi of 0, then
we can calculate pi of 1,
and then in turn calculate pi
of 2, and so on and so forth.
And the general formula
that comes out of this,
after some algebra, is
given by this expression,
which involves pi of 0.
Now, what is pi 0?
Well, we can find it by using
the normalization equation,
the summation of pi i equals 1.
You use this normalization,
replace each pi
i by their quantities
as a function of pi 0,
and then we obtain
this equation for pi 0.
So here, again, we use
that normalization.
We replaced pi i by their value.
We sum to 1, and
we obtain pi of 0.
And then in turn,
from this pi of 0,
you can replace the
pi of 0 in pi of i,
and you obtain a pi of i as a
function of B, lambda, and mu.
So if we know B
and lambda and mu,
we can set up this Markov chain,
and we can calculate pi 0,
and then pi of i for all i's.
We can then answer a
question like this.
After the chain has
run for a long time,
how likely is it that at
any given random time,
you will find the system
with i busy lines?
Well, it will be pi of i.
And also, we can interpret
the steady-state probabilities
as frequencies.
So once I found pi of
i, it also tells me
what fraction of the time
I will have i busy lines.
And you can answer that
question for every possible i.
Now, we were initially
interested in the probability
that the entire system is
busy at any point in time,
in other words, in
that state here.
So if a new phone
call gets placed,
it is going to find the
system in a random state.
That random state is
described in steady-state
by the probability pi's.
And the probability that
the entire system is busy
is going to be given by pi of
B, and this is the probability
that we would like to be small
in a well-engineered system.
So again, given lambda,
mu, the design question
is to find B so that this
probability is small.
Could we figure out a
good value for B by doing
a back-of-the-envelope
calculation?
Well, let's suppose that
lambda is 30 calls per minute.
And let's assume
that mu is 1/3 so
that the mean
duration is 3 minutes.
So on average, a call
lasts for 3 minutes,
and you get 30 calls
on average per minute.
Then how many calls would
be active on the average?
If a call lasted exactly
1 minute, then at any time
you would have 30
calls being active.
Now, a call lasts, on the
average, for 3 minutes.
So by thinking in
terms of averages,
you would expect
that, at any time,
there would be about 90 calls
that are active, 3 times 30.
And if 90 calls are
active on the average,
you could say, OK, I'm going
to set up my B to be 90.
But that's not very good,
because if the average number
of phone calls that want to
happen is, on the average, 90,
sometimes you are
going to have 85,
and sometimes you'll get 95.
And to be sure that the
phone calls will go through,
you probably want
to choose your B
to be a number a
little larger than 90.
How much larger than 90?
Well, this is a question that
you can answer numerically.
By looking at these
formulas, if you
decide that your acceptable
level of service, pi of B,
has to be less than
1%, then you will
find that the B that you need
to design is to be at least 106.
So you actually need some margin
to protect against a situation
if suddenly, by
chance, more people
want to talk than
on an average day.
And if you want to
have a good guarantee
that an incoming person will
have a very small probability
of finding a busy
system, here 1%,
then you will need
about 106 phone lines.
So that's the calculation
and the argument
that Erlang went
through a long time ago.
It's actually interesting that
Erlang did this calculation
before Markov chains
were invented.